[Music]
kate's in ontario hi kate welcome to the
ramsey show
hey dave hey rachel thank you so much
for taking my call dave i have to talk
to you and george back in december my
grandmother passed away and is leaving
me about 150 000
canadian dollars
the probate period's ending i'm probably
going to receive the money at the end of
the month and i'm having a disagreement
with my parents about what i would like
to do with money versus what they would
like me to do with the money i'd really
like to honor both my
grandparents and my parents
how old are you and i just hope your
advice
how old are you
oh i'm 30. why do your parents get a
vote in this
well they gave me 60 000 my husband 50
000 very generously when we bought our
starter home did they give it to you or
did they loan it to you and say they get
to tell you how to run your life after
that
no sir they gave it to us as a very
generous that's sweet that's sweet until
they until they use that as the guilt
trip ticket
so you should and continue to fully fund
our emergency fund which is about
halfway there and then put the rest
towards our mortgage which would pay
about 80 of it down there's two
different things going on here okay
you're asking me what to do with it
and you're discussing your parents
wanting to tell you what to do with it
those are two different subjects okay
okay all right rachel so what i'm
curious what do your parents want you to
do because i just heard what you want to
do what do they want you to do
my parents want me to put it in
retirement accounts basically the
canadian equivalent of roth and ira as
well as do some home repairs
so what's what what is it for you kate
though that that kind of back to dave's
question of that need to
really feel the weight of what they're
saying are they making you feel so
guilty like what
why
why don't you just go and do what you
want to do
they're not making me feel guilty
they're really wonderful people who have
done a lot on their own and they have
really won with money and been great
examples to me that i feel i should but
what you're suggesting you want to do
with money is not dumb
well i didn't think so well no it's not
i mean it's exactly what we teach so
obviously we think it's not dumb but
also i mean you didn't suggest you you
go
uh
you know somehow you blow the money or
you're irresponsible with money
okay
let me run a parallel for you okay
this is how my mind works and i can't
help it um but
you know rachel's little brother daniel
is 31 right
i don't know how old my brother is but
it sounds about right
and so if if he and his wife allison
got a hundred and fifty thousand dollars
i am very loud
i am very opinionated
and when it comes to this particular
subject i'm very right okay
but i still the chances of me
and rachel back me up on this uh the
chances of me
calling daniel and allison up out of the
blue and saying here's what you should
do with money that you got from
allison's parents or got from whatever
other source is zero now if they ask
i'll tell them what i think they should
do
but i'm not going to withhold love
if they don't do it
i'm not going to roll my eyes if they
don't do it
um they're like grown people and stuff
you see is that i mean that's how we
would function right now 100 yes for
sure but but kate i have for you
do you feel like you're going to get
that the role of the eye the oh my gosh
i can't believe you did that kate that
that feeling from your parents or do you
think they're going to say
oh
we just think that this was a better
idea but you go do like
is there that sticking point
i think they might be disappointed that
i maybe didn't take their advice and i
took dave ramsey's advice instead but i
don't think they would
i don't think it would be a thanksgiving
okay dinner i mean here here's the thing
so for you though you're just struggling
between are they right or is this right
sorry go what exactly exactly and i want
to if i go ahead and make like the dave
ramsey stream decision i want to do it
in a way and explain it to them in a way
that you know says that's what i would
like to do and i'd like to honor you and
honor my grandparents in this
absolutely
absolutely so go
he's like dying over here
um
i appreciate you wanting them to be
happy with your decision
but your need for their approval just
needs to stop
okay the boundaries are just they're
they're walking all in your yard with
muddy boots they need to get back in
their yard
they came across they came across the
fence they just came across the fence
and you know you don't have to be mean
about it and i'm not suggesting you be
caustic and this isn't really about
their advisor dave ramsey's advice this
is about like you being a grown up and
stuff and you get to make your decisions
and you decided you were going to you
gathered up information from several
different sources and then you made the
decision what you wanted to do with your
money
it's not like oh i picked dave ramsey
over i picked my parents no you know
you're not doing that that's not what's
going on here what's really going on
here is you gathered information from
several different places you think that
this particular method is the best okay
rachel gathered several pieces of
information from different places and
bought a freaking tesla
how in the world but she did and we're
making you know we make fun of her all
the time but um and we joke about it but
the point is
even as you know we joke about it but
the chances of me she she did not follow
her parental guidance when she purchased
a car that it runs on a battery that her
father would never do that not going to
get it
but i you know all we have done
is
celebrate that she loves the car and
joke about it that's all we've done
there's been no me walking over in your
boundary scene you shouldn't do that
that's a dumb idea stop being stupid i
never i never did any of that no no
but kate i would say when you explain it
to your parents because you're like yeah
they're probably gonna be disappointed
so yes the boundaries is a whole issue i
shouldn't be disappointed i know i'm not
disappointed that you bought a tesla i
make fun of you but i'm not disappointed
no but kate i think too to explain it to
them though like like um
that your quickest way to honor
them honor your grandparents all the
language you're using
and to help you and your family win you
and you your husband win
with money the fastest way to get from
point a to point b of what you see is to
have what's wise as an emergency fund in
the bank you're having an emergency fund
in the bank uh paying off any debt that
you have being able to take some of that
and pay off your mortgage so that way
you guys don't have a mortgage payment
so that so that you can
invest in all that because their advice
is not necessarily it's not the order we
would do it but investing that money
it's not like they're giving you bad
advice you can invest that money and be
totally
great kate but but the steps before that
and explaining to them like hey here's
what here's how i'm seeing it
to be wise to get to that point and then
i will then i will be able to invest and
have the margin to invest a lot i think
john delaney would disagree with you
really to explain it to him no i think
he would just say
listen i appreciate your input you don't
get a vote okay but if kate's not i'm
thinking if i'm in her shoes though and
i feel
like a
oh gosh you know and again this isn't
you guys but i'm like if if i had
parents saying that to me
she she's at the point though that she's
taking their their opinion with such
weight for her to just eliminate that
that doesn't happen overnight so for her
to make this decision though in the next
week you just smile at him and say honey
you don't get a vote
now you can be a little nicer than that
you can be nicer about than that honey
hey you're you didn't tell your mother
and i well the name of your children
before they were born because you were
afraid your mother would roll her eyes
okay she said because we don't get a
vote it's your freaking kid you get to
name the kid we hope you don't name a
moonbeam
but but you get to name the kids my mom
goes oh god please don't name them
anything weird i was like exactly i'm
not telling you the baby names so
exactly you do and all you said was in a
nice way you don't get a vote my kid in
my body i name it
you know and that's that's healthy
boundaries no but what do you say to
kate who doesn't she needs to put up
healthy boundaries she does but i think
having a conversation and explaining why
she's making this decision is not wrong
it's not i don't they don't get a vote
they don't get a vote so they don't need
to be persuaded oh my gosh
no she's making her decision to do the
emergency fund and pay off the mortgage
but i think it's totally fine
relationally to go into her parents and
say hey here's why i've chosen to do it
you don't get a vote but here's why and
explain the why that's not wrong
if you want to it's okay but dial up
delonah you didn't explain me why you
named your kid that and you didn't
explain to me why you bought a tesla and
i still don't want to get gas anymore i
know but i didn't you didn't offer you
didn't owe me an explanation no i
no i don't but if i was worried about it
i probably would give you an explanation
but i'm not worried about it because you
don't care see there it is it's healthy
boundaries that's it you got it
it is wonderful i love it kate bottom
line is do what you wanna do with your
money i would recommend what we always
recommend we hope you do that and we
love you anyway